I sometimes encounter people on the
street that are saying they'll recognize
me and they'll say don't you
uh don't you hate today everything's so
PC you can't say anything and I'll think
no you can oh you can't if you're clever
you can get away with anything well but
also you just limits limits are healthy
and they're part of life all gravity is
acting on us all the time yeah
man what if why why do we got to be held
down because we'd float into space and
die you should be happy that's there I'm
talking about and by the way get get
ready for there there are going to be
periods where AI will become this weird
flavor of the week someone will do
something cool on AI that people will
run to catch up with I always someone
should do it either a documentary or
write a book about the period I want it
it's like
um after Jurassic before the Matrix
after Jurassic Park's park parks after
Jurassic Park came out every movie
suddenly was like Gotta Have CGI that's
what people want to see they want CGI
they didn't realize it no Jurassic Park
still tells a compelling story in his
great filmmaking they weren't just going
to see Sia so you saw it was like a
decade of terrible CGI in films Godzilla
Dragonheart Air Force One escape from La
where they were just putting in CGI
almost as if that was the a star of the
movie and you'll see this CGI and then
it was until the Matrix came along that
then someone took it and took it to the
next level so in other words and now
there's a weird Rebellion against a lot
of Siege a lot of filmmakers are trying
to do practical effects yeah filmmakers
want I mean I think it's one of the
reasons that
the Top Gun movie was so huge in a way
Tom Cruise still has this massive career
because he's willing to go out and kind
of almost kill himself yeah in every
film yeah there's not CGI trickery going
on it's like that dude almost died I
okay so I paid us I'd pay to see that
but there will always be that pushback
of because I think um any kind of new
technology also creates that sense of
like well there's nothing at stake here
you know when I watch Escape From LA and
snake pliskin is surfing alongside Peter
Fonda and it's clearly a computer
generated way I was like no one's
risking their lives making this this
isn't exciting and then their careers
that is true you know what credibility
is the only thing risk yeah but yeah
like and then you see you know there's
always pushback and then the same thing
will happen with comedy someone told me
that in the new Oppenheimer film
that he didn't want to use the director
didn't want to
use any CGI to create what we all know
is the explosion of the first atomic
bomb so instead use like hundreds of
thousands of sticks of dynamite and you
think
okay I actually it would have been it
would have been I mean I haven't seen it
yet I don't know what it looks like but
there was a commitment to no this really
has to look this has to look real in
some way although by the way I think 7
000 people were killed
I'll go see that yeah I'll see that
um sometimes now the cost of CGI at the
level that movies like that want to do
it at it's actually prohibitive cost
wise and it's cheaper to do the real
effect in tenant when that plane crashes
into the airport that was going to be
done CGI and it's all done with a real
plane and real explosives because it was
cheaper to shoot the real thing a CGI
thing would have cost way too much money
and it was quicker to do it that way
because they're just we set up our
cameras and we got to shoot this we we
got to get this in this take whereas
with CJ would have taken an extra six
months and all this extra money and all
these extra crew people and he's like
let's just shoot I love the image of the
cgis guys going well and here's what
it's going to cost and good luck wait
you did what
we just bought a 747 and we packed it
with explosives and we hired a guy to
kill himself and drive it into an
airport we set up a bunch of cameras and
crossed our fingers I mean that by the
way I love I do love watching old I mean
I'm a big I have the Criterion Channel
and Turner Classic Movies because I'm a
film geek and I also love watching old
movies especially old stunts even like
movies in the 70s where you're like uh
someone almost died and and stunt work
back then was okay here we go hope no
one died the car chasing bullet uh is
one of those things where you're
watching it and you think I think
someone did lose their life in the
making of that and but it's one thing to
have a Chase like that in bullet which
was a major Studio Movie I'm talking
even the B level drive in movies people
were almost dying there's a Joe Don
Baker movie
um called framed and there is a stunt
where a train hits a car and a guy has
to jump out out of the car before the
train hits it and it is you when you see
it you'll know it it's that dude almost
died like he barely gets out of the car
clearly something's going wrong and then
as he's jumping the car explodes and the
fireball kind of engulfs him for a
second and then he gets out of it and
they just left it on film and that was
that was done spec that well hope we
don't die and before the stunt when the
car makes a right in the background you
can see the entire crew is all sitting
on bleachers because they want to watch
this like this guy's about to die it's
gonna be great like they just shot this
movie so yes for bullet be like there's
a major movie Steve yeah of course but
this is like Joe Don Baker we're
shooting this in two weeks down in North
Carolina so they told the guy you're
gonna
um you're gonna you're gonna get stalled
in front of a train your job is just to
get out before the train hits but really
wait to the last second if you can and
we're just gonna run a friggin train at
the is look up Joe Don Baker frame and
it says like the most dangerous stunt
you've ever seen and by also even in
common you ever you ever used cars
Robert zemeck this is used cars
there's a scene there's a dude like
walking across a road drunk and this car
is zooming up and barely misses him and
it's done as a joke but you watch if if
what if because the actor is doing this
ah just walking around drunk but he's
just improving it if he had gone the
wrong way the car would have killed him
it's in the middle of a comedy you're
like oh God that guy almost died do you
remember there was a film with Lee
Horsley called Sword and the Sorcerer
And the bad guy God does a high fall off
a cliff and he died but they left it in
the film because he left it yeah and he
it's his death fall is in the movie and
yeah yeah it's crazy because that's what
he signed up for and and in that culture
back then it was like that's how I want
to go yeah leave that in that's how I'd
want to die it's nuts maybe afterwards
me if they were alive for eight seconds
they were like don't leave that in
their teeth are coming through their
chest cavity
[Music]
oh I'm so happy right now
you know
that guy from the history of the world
I guess it might be some kind of a male
or something shut your mouth
these guys both auditioned to be Duke
boys
oh my God what in the hell he catches
fire his leg catches fire don't you get
the sense that he also slows his role so
he can be a little closer yes God that
was fantastic I mean and again and by
the way yeah you can see at one point
you can see the crew is all lined up in
the background watching this but like
fine
you know what that guy got a hundred
dollars a hundred dollars
yeah and they and maybe they comped his
room but like you watch a lot of
Australian uh action films from the 80s
especially like the road warrior there
are stunts in that movie that at the
time they were saying oh no it was all
in the editing because they were right
trying to work in Hollywood but then
there's a documentary about the making
of and there's people just getting
racked up in the Philippines too they're
the oh the Philippines stuff capitalized
anything yeah people would do anything
the biggest thing I notice is editing is
that things are there's uh movies
particularly and TV shows are edited so
tightly yeah that there's hardly any air
and I find it fascinating to go back and
look at a show
like a late 70s
massive hit show like say a chips or
something like that
and the literally a guy will drive up
he's my job is to drive up in a car and
meet with you in a parking lot and so I
drive up in a car and it's supposed to
be a tense scene and I'm here to talk to
you know Pat and Oswalt and tell him to
back off my territory or I'll kill him
if I pull up and I get out of my car I
unhook the belt get out of my car shut
the door
and then start walking and I've parked
like 15 feet 20 feet from you and they
show me walking all the way over to you
and you know you look at how today the
editing is so take another frame out
take another frame out and what we're
seeing everything is so hyper compressed
that I know that when I watched
I was when I was went back and looked at
some of the Late Night with David
Letterman shows that I have been
watching yeah uh and you know adoring in
the 80s when I went back and looked at
them later on I was like
huh it's it's slower than I remember yep
and it's quieter than I remembered and
there's more like there's it's it's it's
not this explosion of fireworks and I
know that okay things the pace ramped up
if you look at the the arc on our show I
know the pace ramped up yep but I bet
you people are gonna go back later and
say this feels slow to me this red not
fit you know and I remember us thinking
like this is so much faster than what
anyone used to do but I think we've
hyper compressed everything